[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a surreal black comedy
dystopian film called the lobster
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the near dystopian future not being
in a relationship is considered a crime
to survive in the world one should
always be with a romantic partner people
must go everywhere with their partners
or else they are punishable by law all
newly single people are brought to a
hotel that gives them a chance to find a
romantic partner in the course of 45
days
if they are unable to find one they are
turned into an animal of their choice
through a modern technique the opening
scene of the movie shows us a woman
driving down a road until she reaches a
field with small donkeys she gets out of
her car and shoots one of the donkeys
until it is dead
the protagonist of the movie is an
architect named david his wife has
recently left him for another man so he
has been brought to the hotel to find
another partner david is with his dog
bob who used to be his brother but was
transformed for having no romantic
partner to check into the hotel david
signs a paper and is interviewed by a
hotel staff member according to the
rules of dating the couple should have a
common defining characteristic david's
defining characteristic is that he is
short-sighted meaning he should look for
a partner who is short-sighted as well
david also reveals that he has been with
his wife for 11 years but she left him
for another shortsighted man
i guess he didn't see it coming
after that he is taken to his room and
is briefed about the rules of the hotel
by the manager and her husband when the
manager asks him what kind of animal he
would like to be if he doesn't find a
partner david replies that he wants to
be a lobster because they live for over
a hundred years and are fertile
throughout their life
he also adds that he loves the sea and
is quite good at swimming the manager
praises his choice of animal claiming
that most choose to be dogs which
affects the ecosystem and the animal
food chain
before they leave the hotel's maid cuffs
one of david's hands to keep him from
pleasuring himself which is against the
hotel's rules good thing david's a lefty
the following day at breakfast he makes
friends with two men one who speaks with
a lisp robert and one who walks with a
limp john
they both are searching for girls with
the same attributes as themselves while
skimming through the dining area they
notice a woman whose nose always bleeds
and a woman who is heartless but there
is no one whose attributes align with
theirs
later during an assembly the singles are
called up to speak and talk about their
unique qualities
john says that he acquired his limp when
he visited his mother who had turned
into a wolf he is here because his wife
died some time ago
similarly the others share their
experiences throughout the day the
singles are given opportunities to talk
to their potential partners at a dance
party david asks the nosebleed girl to
dance with him but realizes that they do
not have a common attribute following
that they're called to go to the woods
to hunt the loners
loners are the people who ran away from
the hotel because they didn't want to be
turned into animals since the police in
the city would send them back to the
hotel they form a colony and stay in the
woods the singles are allowed to hunt
them by shooting them with tranquilizers
then the loners are brought back to the
hotel and turned into animals the number
of loners the singles catch will be
added to the number of days they have
left in the hotel on the first day david
catches none meaning that his days are
going down more rapidly the best hunter
among the singles is the heartless woman
who catches about 10 in a single hunt
the hotel also has weird rules that at
night the maid should arouse the men so
they are interested in finding a partner
quicker
one day robert is found pleasuring
himself and as a punishment his hand is
burnt in a toaster wow this is some
dobby the house elf [ __ ] in their next
hunt david sits next to the woman whose
characteristic feature is that she likes
butter biscuits she talks to david who
shows no interest in her even when she
offers sexual favors while talking she
reveals that she plans to jump out of
the window of her room if she doesn't
get a partner in time
during a swimming lesson john the guy
who limps hits his nose making it bleed
he then approaches the nosebleed girl
lying that his nose bleeds all the time
to match their attributes
at the next evening party john and the
nosebleed girl are pronounced a couple
and are shifted to a double room a few
days later the butter biscuits girl
jumps out of her window and commits
suicide the ruthless girl watches her
whimper in pain but doesn't get up to
help her
now david only has a week left to find
himself a girl so he approaches the
heartless girl acting like he doesn't
care for people's lives either the woman
is looking for someone who has no
emotions like her so she is attracted to
david they hang out and talk for a while
throughout which david keeps up the act
one day they are in a hot tub where the
woman fakes her death to see if david
cares
however he stays in his seat and ignores
her completely
this makes the woman realize that he is
actually like her and she starts to date
him they are even put together in a
double room and allowed to perform
activities reserved for only couples
like playing tennis and sitting at a
table for two they stay as a couple for
a few days but the ruthless girl notices
david showing emotions when they get
intimate so one morning she kicks his
brother's bob to death to test him david
says that it is no problem at first but
then the woman finds him crying in the
bathroom she drags him through the
hallways to take him to the manager for
lying but david knocks her out with a
tranquilizer gun before she can the maid
watches him do so and promises to not
tell anyone
to take revenge for his brother david
thinks of kicking her in the stomach
again and again but settles to another
plan he and the maid get her to the
transformation room and turn her into an
animal following that david runs away
from the hotel once and for all in the
woods he meets a group of loners and
their leader one might think he is
finally with good people but the leader
is as ruthless as the hotel manager she
punishes the loners for having romantic
or sexual relationships with each other
they also informed david that two
people's lips were cut off a few days
ago because they were flirting after
they explain the rules he is welcomed to
the group
one of the loner girls with black hair
and short-sightedness like david looks
at him for the first time and is
instantly attracted to him but because
of the loner's rule she only talks to
him as a friend in the evening when the
hotel guests come for the hunt robert
catches david david tries to save his
life claiming that robert is his best
friend but the guy is adamant about
catching him because he only has two
days left the black-haired girl hits him
from behind and saves david's life at
the same time we see the maid of the
hotel meeting with the lead loner it
turns out that the two meet every time
she comes hunting to inform the leader
about what is going on at the hotel the
maid is not happy with her husband but
doesn't want to leave him because she
will end up in the hotel as a guest
so she and the leader are planning to
attack the hotel and take over it
once every month two people from the
loner's crew pretend to be a couple and
go outside to the city to get food and
other supplies
this time the leader and her partner
take the black-haired girl and david in
the mall a police officer sees david
alone and questions him about his
partner demanding a marriage certificate
from him but the dark-haired girl saves
him from the man
some days later the loners finally get
ready to attack the hotel
that night they sneak inside with the
maid's help and hold the manager and her
husband hostage they ask the husband to
shoot his wife dead if he wants to save
his own life the guy doesn't care about
his wife at all so he shoots her without
hesitating but it turns out that the gun
was unloaded and the purpose of the
abduction was to show the couple they do
not care about each other and are in a
hollow relationship
at the same time david visits jon and
the nosebleed girl and reveals to her
that he is faking the nosebleed so that
they could be together the loners leave
abruptly after proving their point and
return back to the woods
that night the maid joins the loner
group in the course of the next few days
the black-haired girl and david get
closer and start liking each other they
even plan to run away from the group so
they can be together the girl writes all
of this in her journal but before they
can execute their plan the leader reads
the journal and gets to know about their
affair she is enraged by the betrayal
but doesn't confront them instead some
days later she takes the dark-haired
girl to the city claiming that she will
fix her short-sightedness
but instead makes her go blind
after returning to the woods the
dark-haired girl finds out what is going
on and tries to kill the leader in the
attempt she kills the hotel's maid
instead the leader spares her and lets
her go to david at first she tries to
hide the fact that she has gone blind
but then comes clean she is scared that
he will leave her now that they do not
have any matching attributes
david is unsettled but decides that he
wants to stay with her and helps her out
with her other senses of touch and smell
for the next few days they try to find
other attributes that they might have in
common but are unsuccessful david
doesn't want to let go of her so he
suggests they kill the leader and run
away from the woods they put their plan
into action at night david abducts the
leader and throws her into an open grave
a while later some wild dogs approach
her and start devouring her body
meanwhile he and the dark-haired girl
dress up and run away from the woods
eventually they stop at a diner in the
city david has decided to blind himself
so the two have matching qualities they
talk for a while about the decision and
ask the waiter for a knife
david gets up and goes to the bathroom
to blind himself but stops midway the
movie ends abruptly without showing if
they ever lived a normal life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching